get ready for takeoff everyone because a
new trailer was just released for disney
and pixar's animated new film light year
which of course revolves around the
story of buzz lightyear from the toy
story franchise
yes chris evans voices buzz as he heads
out on an intergalactic space adventure
where he's accompanied by a talking
robot cat named socks and takes on the
evil emperor zerg are you guys excited
for this i know i am jeff
why not i like more buzz lightyear
contact he's one of my favorites so why
not
all right everyone take a look and we
will see you tomorrow bye
a year of work for a four-minute flight
isn't that something we're all ready if
you are sir well let's go find out if
this
we got a breach in the perimeter
thank you
buzz lightyear mission log
after a full year of being marooned on
this planet
our first test flight is a go
let's get everyone home good luck
captaining
roger that
[Applause]
[Music]
your personal companion robot
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
right here
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no white noise
is fine very well good night socks good
night buzz